bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 politique le dernier de
l'année et ce soir ce sont des nouveaux
élus à la région dont nous allons parler
invité tout à l'heure ramatoulaye à sale
pour les socialistes
elle est également conseillère
d'opposition au conseil municipal de
mantes-la-jolie et puis malgré ce que
nous vous avions annoncé othman nasri
pour les républicains ne sera pas
présent en plateau pour raisons de santé
lui aussi fait partie de ces nouveaux
élus à la région je vous propose pour
débuter de revenir sur l'installation de
ce nouveau conseil c'était le 18
décembre dernier
le reportage est signée william l
vendredi dernier le conseil régional
d'île de france a basculé à droite après
avoir été présidées par la gauche
pendant 17 ans valérie pécresse la
candidate du parti républicain a été
élue présidente du conseil régional
d'île de france
dès son élection avec 119 voix sur 140
exprimer la nouvelle présidente a
rappelé son engagement dans sa lutte
contre la métropole du grand paris a
réaffirmé son souhait de déménager le
conseil régional en banlieue je crois
que nous devons partir de l'autre côté
du périphérique vous savez aujourd'hui
l'argent public est rare
l'argent public est fier il ya beaucoup
de francs signale qu'ils ont du mal à
boucler leurs fins de mois ne pouvons
pas gérer la région à partir de tel
particulier du 7e arrondissement
nous avons cinq hôtels particuliers et
26 millions d'euros de locaux dispersés
dans tout paris je pense qu'on peut
fractionner lisez tout ça et faire
beaucoup d'économies un nouveau visage
pour ce conseil régional la gauche étant
maintenant passer dans l'opposition avec
66 sièges contre 121 pour la droite
c'est une page qui se tourne en ile de
france
ce que va livrer pécresse
c'est désormais présidente va mettre en
oeuvre j'imagine le programme pour
laquelle elle a été élue nous on
défendra une autre vision
de l'île de france notamment en terme de
solidarité
de protection des services publics
l'idée c'est d'être dans ce docu sur
constructive alors on est là tous au
service des franciliens un total de 209
conseillers pour une assemblée avec un
nouveau visage puisque le front national
n'ont représenté auparavant y siègent
avec 22 élus sur la sécurité les mesures
de maps et que mam pécresse à amis dans
son programme sont pour nous des
mesurettes ne suffira pas à rétablir la
sécurité
sa demande d des moyens ça demande des
ressources en hommes se demande de la
vidéo surveillance ça demande un centre
régional de vidéosurveillance avec
réaction en temps réel voilà ça c'est
tout ça qu'on va demander à grand
renfort de vote et de présence et de et
de nos voix un combat pour la présidence
de la région menée depuis douze ans par
valérie pécresse
il saluait par la droite devenue
majoritaire bien souvent il y avait des
désaccords sur bien des sujets des
sujets basique et fondamentaux il
fallait venir combler à 52 voix pour que
des sujets de lui il se passer voilà le
vrai sentiment c'est l'humilité
de l'humilité
on va commencer vite à travailler voilà
on va commencer vitesse lamballe previti
mettre en place on va on va être
efficace
après son élection dans l'hémicycle la
nouvelle présidente s'est rendu au siège
du conseil régional on rue barbet de
jouy pour une passation de pouvoir dans
cette région
ici nous avons vu et il fallait humanité
et bienveillant un moment chargé
d'émotion pour l'ancien président jean
paul huchon qui quitter ses locaux qu'il
présidait depuis 17 ans dans un instant
je recevrai ramatoulaye s à l'élue
socialiste en ile de france elle siège
pour la première fois et puisque l'on
parle des socialistes cumul des mandats
et un mot sur la situation de venoix
hamon le député déi mines qui avait
quitté son poste de conseiller régional
lors de la précédente mandature il a été
élu une nouvelle fois donc abattent il
quitter son poste de député voici sa
réponse pour l'instant je suis dans le
cadre de la loi donc j'ai le droit
d'être député et conseiller régional
heureusement
le jour où et j'espère que ça changera
pas je poserai la question dès 2017 du
non cumul entre un mandat exécutif et un
mandat de parlementaire ce qui ne me
concerne pas si vous a pas échappé
ça se posera à d'autres élus notamment
sur les bancs de la droite mais pas moi
nous continuons ce 7,8 politique je
reçois présent ramatoulaye salle bonsoir
et bienvenue sur ce plateau nouvelle
élue socialiste à la région ile de
france vous aussi dans l'opposition
conseil municipal elle demande la jolie
je voudrais avoir votre sentiment sur la
démission de claude bartolone il porter
votre liste il a décidé de ne pas siéger
dans l'opposition est ce que c'est une
bonne décision je bonsoir il tient son
engagement je pense que ce qu'attendent
les français ce qu'ils ont revendiqué de
manière assez importante c'est aussi
d'avoir des élus qui se consacrent à
leur tâche claude bartolone a fait le
choix de ce pont sera consacrée à
l'assemblée nationale de conserver son
mandat de député et de laisser aussi
parce que c'était sa philosophie très
tôt dans la campagne de laisser la
nouvelle génération
prendre de l'espace s'investir dans le
show politique est compris dans le sens
politique régionale donc mais quand on
sait qu'en voyant dix ans la région
c'est toute ma vie la région c'est mon
engagement et quand on est battu et
qu'on se retire c'est pas aussi un petit
peu difficile pour les électeurs qui ont
voté pour lui mais les électeurs vous
savez ils ont voté aussi pour une liste
qui avait un sens qui porte des idées et
progressistes de protection de leur
quotidien ils les électeurs ont voté
pour ça et puis après ils ont voté pour
des personnes qu'ils incarnaient claude
bartolone bien évidemment l'incarner
mais la diversité de la liste fait que
même s'il décide de se consacrer à son
mandat de parlementaire
les choses continueront à être à être
porté sur l'échec des socialistes
peut-être on peut revenir là dessus
aussi
étant donné que la gauche en tout cas
c'était aussi le message qui était
portée par claude bartolone y avait une
certaine fierté une certaine victoire à
l'issue du premier tour la gauche était
le premier parti si on cumule toutes les
voies ça n'a pas suffi pour l'emporter
est ce que vous faites partie de ces
socialistes qui jugeait que l'entre-deux
tours étaient mauvais pour claude
bartolone il ya eu notamment cette
phrase puisqu'il a accusé la députée des
yvelines de défendre neuilly versailles
et la race blanche ça c'était envers
valérie pécresse qui a donc été depuis
déjà il faut quand même me replacer les
choses dans leur contexte un peu plus
large que simplement regarder le premier
tour effectivement on a fait un score
qui nous a surpris un très bon score
pour la gauche rassemblée au premier
tour en tout cas quand on faisait le
cumul des résultats de la douleur
toujours est il que
la politique française fait que la
personne qui arrive en tête et en
dynamique
nous on était moins dynamique fonctionne
a réussi à faire rassemblement d'idées
avec les verts et le parti communiste
tout cas le front de gauche ça nous
était plus difficile de pouvoir emporter
puis par ailleurs tous les sondages
avant on disait que c'était très
difficile pour nous on a fait un
résultat honorable à l'issue du premier
tour et on n'a pas réussi à transformer
l'essai quand même une sortie de route
un écart qui a coûté aussi quelques voix
parce que finalement ça a été assez
serré vous savez hier entoure cette
petite phrase justement la députée des
yvelines défend denis versailles la race
blanche
mais vous savez en fait que vous
regardez la liste de madame pécresse et
les idées qu'elle quelle défense sont
pas des idées pour défendre le quotidien
des habitants des yvelines ni ceux de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nice et du
mantois
ce sont effectivement des pros des
propositions qui défendent une certaine
catégorie de la population après les
maladresses ça arrive à tout le monde y
compris quand on a énormément
d'expérience toujours est il que le fond
de l'idée là c'est un programme qui
défend une certaine catégorie de la
population et qui a une certaine vision
ce qu'il a voulu dénoncer la priorité
pour valérie pécresse sécurité emploi
l'a évoqué alors de l'art de la
cérémonie de l'installation du conseil
régional dont on a parlé au tout début
de cette édition
votre avis sur ces deux priorités
sécurité en toi c'est pas les missions
principales
en tout cas pour la question de la
sécurité c'est bas les missions
principales de la région ile-de-france
arrière plusieurs médias ont déjà noté
le fait que c'était pas du tout dans les
compétences de la région
c'est qu'elle propose et mâcha temps de
voir janvier elle a dit qu'elle allait
présenté son pacte sécurité j'attends de
voir s'il saura je serai vigilante soit
moi je pense que ce que les habitants
d'ile-de-france ont besoin aujourd'hui
c'est pas en numéro 1 la sécurité en
numéro deux la protection collective
c'est des perles et les gens aujourd'hui
dans une période de crise dans laquelle
on vit ils ont besoin qu'on leur
améliore leur quotidien avec les armes
que la région 1 qui sont pas des armes
un infini mais qu'on puisse leur
apporter des protections par ailleurs
principal propre protection et première
protection
c'est la question de leur pouvoir
d'achat mais moi je serai vigilante au
passe navigo ce qu'il reste à 70 euros
parce que madame pécresse il ya un an
s'y opposer et lé financement aussi il
va falloir trouver le financement
le financement est déjà à fait un par
hergé en production n'est pas partie en
mettant de passe à 70 euros et en allant
par la petite porte il a assuré les
financements discuter avec les chefs
d'entreprise qui ont accepté donc
aujourd'hui on a un dispositif qui est
viable économiquement et la question
c'est est ce qu'on va vouloir le faire
continuer politiquement je n'en suis pas
complètement convaincu et moi je
m'assurais demain au conseil régional
condé qui fricote parce qu'on a fait
d'utile pour les habitants d'île de
france comment vous allez poser
justement au sein de ce conseil ce
conseil régional maintenant dans
l'opposition alors est-ce qu'il y aura
une voix unie aussi avec les verts et le
front de gauche qui ont été vos alliés
dans l'entre-deux tours on verra comment
ça va se passer je pense qu'on aura des
batailles communes puisque on a
travaillé ensemble et puis sur d'autres
sujets peut-être pas tout est à
construire demain on verra aussi en
fonction de comment réagit la majorité
la nouvelle majorité à la tête de la
région ile de france
je pense que si on agit pour le bien
être des enfants des français n'y a pas
de raison par contre si on s'attaque à
leurs droits alors là vous aurez une
gauche qui serait vigilante et qui
tapera du poing sur la table
si on parle un peu de vous à présent
vous avez découvert cette assemblée
régionale le 18 décembre lors de
l'installation comment ça s'est passé
en tant que ça et ils l'ont déjà très
long
mais j'y suis allée comme comme comme je
m'y attendais finalement j'ai pas
découvert un environnement radicalement
différent que ce que je pouvais
connaître au préalable
j'ai entendu le discours de madame
pécresse j'ai regardé aussi la
composition de ses vice présidente parce
que ça veut dire quelque chose c'est un
message qu'on a envoyé et puis je suis
assez dubitatif sur le fait qu'un seul
vice-président détiennent les deux tiers
de la dette du budget de la région ile
de france mais je ne suis pas sûr du
fait que ça puisse fonctionner de la
sorte
voilà j'étais sur l'aspect humain aussi
vous comment vous l'avez ressenti ce
moment mais avec de l'émotion évidemment
quand on est élus dans une assemblée
aussi grande
on saisit là la tâche qui est la nôtre
donc effectivement une beaucoup
d'émotions en 2014 les inrocks vous avez
consacré un portrait et vous présentez
comme la jeune ps qui monte
il avait bien vu à l'époque justement
vous étiez candidate aux municipales à
montreuil je ne sais pas s'il avait bien
vu considérée comme la jeune ps qui
monte je sais je sais pas je ne sais pas
pour des jeunes je le suis de moins en
moins de 30 ans jeune je suis moins en
moins et puis ce qui est certain c'est
que j'ai à coeur de défendre les
habitants de mon territoire que c'est ce
qui a poussé à mon engagement
politique et que dès lors que je peux
apporter quelque chose d'évident de mon
territoire défendent leurs intérêts les
accompagner essayer de résoudre des
problèmes faciliter leurs démarches je
le ferai la saab le mans néanmoins vous
êtes tout de même une jeune élue moins
de 30 ans est ce qu'il ya un
renouvellement qui s'opèrent justement
dans les partis politiques on a souvent
pointé du doigt les formations
politiques avec ces élus qui
s'accrochent à leur mandat
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous sentez un
petit peu que les choses évoluent parce
que c'est difficile pour une jeune et
lui aussi
ce qui est certain c'est que quand on
veut imposer le renouvellement des jets
faut l'imposer donc ça va pas de soi et
moi je salue à ce titre-là l'action
claude bartolone puisqu'il a voulu
renouveler les équipes il a voulu faire
en sorte qu' on puisse avoir de
nouvelles pousses qui viennent peut-être
aussi pour apporter un point de vue
différent pour les époux rapporté une
sensibilité différente ont compris dans
la proche qu'on peut avoir des problèmes
environnementaux de sécurité et
problèmes sociaux ce qui n'est pas
forcément le cas chez pécresse en fait
quand vous regardez la composition de sa
liste notamment la liste yvelinoise bien
sûr il y avait des jeunes élus mais il
ya aussi beaucoup beaucoup de maires il
ya beaucoup de députés il ya beaucoup de
cumulards il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui sont là depuis très longtemps dans
le paysage politique que ce soit
nationale ou yvelinois il y en a aussi
du côté de la gauche le député qui siège
à la région
là aussi il y en a aussi mais ça
n'empêche pas que proportionnellement
qu'on ne vous regardez les deux listes
et que vous les mettez l'une à côté de
l'autre je vous le dis vous et moi je
les regardais que ça m'a frappée de voir
au fur et à mesure d'un député député
député maire comme si la jeune
génération ne pouvait pas exister en
tout cas devait exister en jouant des
coudes au milieu de tout ça remet c'est
pas la volonté qu'a eu mme claude
bartelone font que j'en suis la preuve
j'étais numéro 5 des yvelines je suis
pas sûr que quand vous regardez
l'ensemble des autres listes qu'elle
soit 2,2 droite principalement ou de
gauche il est aussi fortement inscrit le
fait qu'on veuille apporter un souffle
nouveau sur le parti socialiste est sûre
cette idée d'apporter un nouveau point
de vue c'est ce que vous avez évoqué
justement vous êtes plutôt partisane
d'une ligne à gauche de la gauche
du côté de benoît hamon avec qui vous
avez d'ailleurs vous avez d'ailleurs
travaillé aujourd'hui quel regard vous
portez sur parti socialiste est-ce qu'il
doit se renouveler est ce qu on entend
aussi parler d'une nouvelle formation
rebaptisé redéfinir le parti socialiste
c'est important aujourd'hui ça se pose
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il ne doit
jamais et que nous doit jamais perdre de
vue les personnes qui ont voté pour nous
qui nous ont fait confiance qu'elle nous
ait fait confiance en 2012 ou à qui nous
est fait confiance avant ou après par
ailleurs parce que je crois que c'est
mitterand qui le disait quand la droite
vous travaillez vous m'ont finalement
c'est pas très grave vous en avez
l'habitude départ de manière assez
paradoxale vous y attendez quand c'est
la gauche qui est qui vous qui vous
trahit qui vous ment là les déplacements
plus importantes et les plus difficile
de reconstruire quelque chose derrière
donc la certitude que j'en ai moi c'est
que il faut ne jamais perdre le cap ne
jamais oublier les personnes qui vous
ont une jeune élue avec des idées
nouvelles mais qui s'inspire de
mitterrand malgré tout wim parce que
j'ai pas honte de mon héritage je pense
qu'il faut savoir d'où l'on vient pour
savoir où on va pour terminer vous
disiez alors je reviens à ce portrait
des inrocks que j'essaie tout à l'heure
vous disiez la politique n'est pas un
métier
vous voyez où dans quelques années vous
dans une ong envie de faire ça j'ai
donné de montant une fin en soi que
c'est aussi c'est aussi non c'est pas
une fin en soi part je pense que c'est
un moment c'est bien de pouvoir avoir le
temps de donner signe en avoir du temps
à donner pour les autres et s'investir
dans la politique j'y invite tout le
monde à le faire
et sincèrement ce que je pense que ça
vous apporte autant que vous puissiez
vous pouvez apporter aux autres mais il
faut aussi savoir en sortir pour ça que
je suis par exemple pour le non cumul
des mandats dans le temps
je pense que vous se l'appliqué aussi
donc dans quelques années ou là qui
avoue même merci
d'être venu en plateau cette édition du
22 décembre consacré à l'installation de
ce nouveau conseil régional en ile de
france
ils sont 31 élus toutes formations
confondues a représenté le département
des yvelines et ils sont 20 pour les
yvelines a siégé pour la première fois
on se retrouve le 12 janvier pour le 7-8
politique avec une émission dédiée à
cette fois la nouvelle agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines excellent de
fêtes de fin d'année